[Music]
aim catfish murder news submitted by
love from New York a millionaire catfish
tricks several teens into murdering a
girl for a nine million dollar reward
about this million dollars Oh would you
know I can't take that's such a random
number that's a big number
yeah my but it's like Mountain yeah like
my wife's weird yeah so the stories come
sad so teenagers in Alaska they are
facing murder charges for killing their
19 year old friend and dumping her body
in a river they shot her like they found
her and shot her in the head weight
bounder means tighter yeah okay and then
uh so this all started when one of the
teens started talking online with this
person who claimed to be a no and this
millionaire was I think from like
Oklahoma or somewhere in like one of the
flyover States and [ __ ] you fly over
Oklahoma and so okay and they those
canvas okay I'm just kidding all that
sorry
they claimed to be from Candace Kansas
but in reality he was from Indiana and
so huh such a random thing to lie about
like I didn't want to reveal his true
identity so like you just make up
everything like so he is 21 years old
his name is Darren Wow and he likes it
like I said he met online with one of
the teens they develop a relationship
he's told that girl that his name was
Tyler and provided fake photos and then
so he like through this relationship he
had her sexually assault a 15 year old
and a 9 year old and then and so this
chick wait she actually did that females
or males what's he saying like I'm gonna
give you money if you do this yes so he
like God she said that he directed her
to set
assault two miners one who was eight or
nine oh my god did she do it so
investigators aren't able to find videos
of the younger child but they did find
that he that she sent him child porn
that featured the 15 year old victim
wait so how does she know these victims
I don't sales friends they don't mention
it just that they mentioned that he
wanted her to do that right so like he
had her do that and he also had her kill
like he wanted her to kill someone and
send him photos of the murder
yeah is he really a millionaire no he's
not he's a 21 year old from Indiana like
he's he catfished her into thinking that
he was a millionaire and thinking that
she was gonna be getting nine mil out of
this so she got some some of her friends
to help with this how old is she 18 yeah
so a teenager and she invited her best
friend Cynthia on a hike and so that's
when Denali
who's the girl we're talking about the
18 year old girl we're talking about
Denali had a 16 year old friend named
Caden to join them on that hike and then
that's when Caden helped the Denali by
finding Cynthia's feet a year old the
best friend the best friend ten year old
help the 18 year old kill the 19 year
old by the hands the feet the mouth with
duct tape sorry
duct tape and then he the sixteen year
old kid shot her in the back of the head
oh my god to the night the 18y didn't
even pull the trigger no and then after
murdering Cynthia they dumped her body
in a nearby river and then they texted
her family saying that they were
dropping her off at a park but then
that's when they ended up burning all of
Cynthia's belongings at another location
and so Cynthia's father is saying like
you know like my daughter trusted these
people my daughter just wanted to have
friends because she had a disability
where I made
her operate at a seventh grade level far
they know like he was like that's why
they targeted her because she just
wanted to me she trusted them yeah all
these people are so evil how can you be
that you okay in their heads like how
does this play out for them so they
killed her friend they're like sick
we're gonna have mega millions of
dollars yeah exactly we're gonna have
nine million dollars and then people are
like how did you make that money and
they're like oh I murdered my [ __ ]
friend do you remember hold you were it
what were your mind was eating i
wouldn't murder to get money that's
that's for sure but I feel like I was
gonna ask is it for money or was she in
love with the guy money but but she was
in a relationship with him right well
there's I mean they developed a develop
a or in a relationship like not
necessarily it doesn't specify like it
was a romantic relationship but have you
guys ever heard of this game called like
white whale or something like that oh
yeah yeah did you guys know about that
so oh so basically what it is is like
there's like these guys on the internet
and like let's say I asked if like on
the internet I'm like hey you want to
play with blue well with me and like
basically me I tell you what to do every
single day and you have to listen to me
and you have to do everything I tell you
like I'm like your master and basically
you have to send me proof so on the
first day I'll be like like cut a piece
of your hair off you know so it's simple
so you don't think it's a big deal you
do it you send it to me and then every
day it gets increasingly worse and then
the ending game and like the goal of the
game is for you to kill yourself so if I
get you to kill yourself
it means that I want but why would the
person agree to that what do they think
they're getting out of it in the
beginning they don't know they're just
like oh I'm playing this game like not a
lot of people made it out like I think
it's that escalation of like that it's
like it can you do it Derek you're also
being sleep-deprived during not looking
like the one staying out like 5 a.m.
yeah like I'm like don't don't sleep and
then the next day it's like go to the
top of a building and look down and then
go to the top of the building look down
and put a foot out you know what I mean
little by little and you don't realize
so the first time you like cut a piece
of your hair these are also children
that's right ray okay yeah here's some
photos this is Cynthia oh she's the one
that got killed
oh so [ __ ] up and then this is the
girl that started talking to the guy and
then these guys are the ones that helped
her why is it always white people yeah I
do this sadistic ash yeah and then she
was also saying during the the court
stuff she's like oh you know I don't
want my daughter to grow up she's a
daughter yeah so she had a daughter that
she put up for adoption
Oh like she's not in her life but like
she's even trying to like get sympathy
from oh she's using the fact that she
had a baby so she was just a mess to
begin with and that's oh she was even
able to get baited like that she kind of
looks like inbred so there might be some
more like crosswire look like they're
missing - maybe you should restate that
just to be safe
inbreds I don't know I'm not gonna
restate that inbred gets people like
just look like that I'm white I could
say that that's a part of my culture
okay so this is the guy oh Lord
they all look like they're from the same
family he didn't send those pictures he
sent a fake picture right yeah [ __ ] this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
all of them I feel like I'd be like a
Justin Bieber picture tell you're gonna
do this make she'd be into that it's
just kind of insane like again we go
like we talked about in the other video
but like when you don't know where you
stand or who you are or all these things
like you would do [ __ ] like this you
know what your minds open to the 17 year
old you're like oh my god nine million I
can buy a house you know even though you
need way less you like yeah I can buy a
house without it and then not have to
work for a lot of year but even that
only lasts you like a few years but you
don't know that like even like when
you're young you're like 1 million
dollars I'm a million yeah forever
I was young on my the first time I held
the thousand-dollar check I was like oh
my god I know I remember my first job I
got paid 300 and like it's check or a
month no it was a month it was a hundred
a month and I thought I'm like I made it
[Music]
[Laughter]
or was a lot yeah especially yeah yeah
I'm into mum wage officially in Downey
ha the minimum wage was 575 yes there's
[ __ ] like that yeah that looks like $13
I think it's up to 11 but don't you guys
think it's also the parents fault also
for not like monitoring with the older
two dude and like how easy it is it to
like sneak around on your phone yeah
like there's a beam on or you don't even
that like I thought you were gonna say
something like the way that these kids
were raised like there has to be
something wrong trouble begets trouble
like their parents are probably trashed
or have money problems or something like
some sort of for her to already have
been pregnant and then given the kid to
adoption you probably already know that
she even comes in state unstable yeah
like it's just there's a lot of people
out there [ __ ] and wait different
situations and we can't even imagine
right I know right she could have been
abused and you know I mean not to say
it's okay I'm like adult excusing her
behavior but try to figure out the
psychology behind it yeah like even when
you guys saw her you're like oh my gosh
it looks like that like dude it's crazy
what some people look like you know what
I mean like you don't not because it's
not in your direct circle this immune
doesn't exist you know and I and I feel
bad because like I want to know more
about this girl and how she got here and
I think that's why I like America's so
obsessed with like serial killers and
like people that do [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
it's like how can you get so far gone to
be a 18 year old and then shoot this
like mentally handicapped girl in the
back of the head and it's like how do
you do that it's like I want to look
into it see how that happens
and that's why I asked like was she
emotionally involved with this man
because it's like pimps and prostitutes
you know like how do you put yourself
through hours of sexual labor with
disgust
man just to give the money over to
someone else you know like we can't
think of that because we're like [ __ ]
not keep the money or I just want to do
it you know but where you're in that
situation like you think this is your
boyfriend and he loves you and you want
to support him you know like it's
[ __ ] or like all of Charles Manson's
girls yeah yeah like they you just get
brainwashed yeah and cult cult leaders
yeah where does it come from even in the
men that are brainwashing them olena a
sociopath or psychopath or whatever that
that's just a gene that's like well the
women might be too it's like a they have
the codependent gene or whatever the
thing is they're like the thing where
they can get manipulated Yahweh damn
yeah she's crazy right now that guy from
Indiana is awaiting extradition to
Alaska to face all of these charges he's
also being charged as well as that girl
for child porn because of that so yeah
yeah reminds me of the making a murderer
thing with the have you seen making a
murderer - yeah oh I don't even finish
the first they dig deeper or like the
Brendan's brother Brendan's the kid that
got locked up because he got coerced
into like whatever his testimony but his
brother had this computer that was
filled with like dead girls like porn to
type stuff like dead girl fetishes and
then like like child porn like all kinds
of that [ __ ] wait what do you think it
was the brother in the neighbor yeah
right yeah like after after making a
murder or two I think that but they're
like each other's alibi like yeah I saw
him going out to fish and like oh I saw
him they're each other's alibi I think
it's them it was them - for sure I mean
but like it's also I've been like okay
well it really seems that way but it's
also documentary that the documentary is
skewing it that way - but it's just hard
to like the stuff they bring up I'm like
[ __ ] like cuz at the end of a strong
point yeah there's a really strong point
and the boss ass lawyer lady I'm like
she's so good
[Music]